que la número 15 seguro será un éxito.
Cuando muchos de nosotros pensamos en innovación, sin embargo,
pensamos en un Einstein con un momento "¡Ajá!".
Pero todos sabemos que eso es un mito.
La innovación no tiene que ver con un genio solitario,
sino con un genio colectivo.
Pensemos un minuto en lo que se necesita para hacer una película de Pixar:
A esas películas no las produce un genio solitario, ni una chispa de inspiración.
Al contrario, requiere cerca de 250 personas, durante 4 o 5 años,
hacer una de esas películas.
Para ayudar a entender el proceso,
un individuo en el estudio dibujó una versión de esta imagen.
Lo hizo a regañadientes,
porque sugería que el proceso era una serie ordenada de pasos
realizado por grupos discretos.
Incluso con todas esas flechas, pensó que realmente no muestra
lo iterativo, interrelacionado y, francamente, desordenado que era.
La historia se desarrolla al hacer una película de Pixar.
Pensemos en ello.
Algunas tomas salen rápido.
No todas salen en orden.
Depende del porte de los desafíos
de cada escena en particular.
Si piensan en la escena de "Up"
en la que el niño le pasa el trozo de chocolate al ave,
el acabado de esos 10 segundos demandaron 6 meses de un animador.
Otro aspecto de una película de Pixar
es que ninguna parte de la película se considera terminada
hasta que toda la película está terminada.
En cierto punto de una producción, un animador dibujó un personaje
con una ceja arqueada que sugería un lado travieso.
Cuando el director vio ese dibujo, pensó que era genial.
Era hermoso, pero dijo:
"Tienes que desecharlo; no encaja con el personaje".
Dos semanas más tarde el director volvió y dijo:
"Pongamos esos pocos segundos del film".
Gracias a que al animador se le permitió compartir
lo que denominamos "su rebanada de genio"
pudo ayudar al director a repensar el personaje
de una manera sutil pero importante que mejoraba la historia.
Sabemos que en el corazón de la innovación hay una paradoja.
Hay que dar rienda suelta a los talentos y las pasiones de muchas personas
y aprovecharlos para que el trabajo sea útil.
La innovación es un viaje.
Es un tipo de resolución de problemas colaborativa
por lo general de personas que tienen distintas experiencias
y distintos puntos de vista.
Las innovaciones rara vez se crean de una vez.
Como muchos saben,
por lo general, son el resultado de prueba y error.
Hay muchos falsos comienzos, tropiezos y errores.
El trabajo innovador puede ser muy estimulante,
pero también puede ser francamente aterrador.
Cuando vemos por qué Pixar puede hacer lo que hace,
tenemos que preguntarnos, ¿qué sucede aquí?
Por supuesto, la historia y, ciertamente, Hollywood,
está llena de equipos plagados de estrellas, que han fracasado.
La mayoría de esos fracasos se atribuyen
a demasiadas estrellas o demasiados cocineros, si se quiere, en la cocina.
Entonces ¿por qué Pixar, con tantos cocineros,
tiene éxito una y otra vez?
Cuando estudiamos un banco islámico de Dubái,
o una marca de lujo en Corea, o una empresa social en África,
encontramos que las organizaciones innovadoras
son comunidades que tienen 3 capacidades:
abrasión creativa, agilidad creativa y resolución creativa.
La abrasión creativa es poder crear un mercado de ideas
mediante el debate y el discurso.
En las organizaciones innovadoras, se amplifican las diferencias,
no se minimizan.
La abrasión creativa no es una lluvia de ideas,
en la que las personas suspenden su juicio.
No, ellos saben cómo tener acaloradas discusiones pero argumentos constructivos
para crear una cartera de alternativas.
Los individuos en las organizaciones innovadoras
aprenden a indagar, a escuchar activamente, pero ¿adivinen qué?
También aprenden a defender sus puntos de vista.
Entienden que la innovación rara vez sucede
a menos que haya diversidad y conflicto.
La agilidad creativa es poder probar y refinar esa cartera de ideas
mediante búsqueda rápida, reflexión y ajuste.
Es aprendizaje por descubrimiento
es actuar, en lugar de planificar el camino hacia el futuro.
Es el "pensamiento de diseño" en el que existe esa combinación interesante
de método científico y proceso artístico.
Es ejecutar una serie de experimentos, y no una serie de pilotos.
Los experimentos son sobre aprendizaje.
Cuando uno tiene un resultado negativo,
realmente aprende algo que necesita saber.
Los pilotos a menudo tienen que ver con tener razón.
Cuando no funcionan, alguien o algo tiene la culpa.
La capacidad final es la resolución creativa.
Esto tiene que ver con tomar una decisión
en la que uno puede combinar incluso ideas opuestas
para reconfigurarlas en nuevas combinaciones
y producir una solución nueva y útil.
Las organizaciones innovadoras nunca conceden para llevarse bien.
No llegan a soluciones de compromiso.
No permiten que un grupo o un individuo domine,
incluso si es el jefe, incluso si es el experto.
En cambio, han desarrollado
un proceso de decisión más bien paciente y más inclusivo
que les permite soluciones AMBAS / Y
y no solo soluciones ALGUNA / O.
Por estas 3 capacidades vemos
que Pixar puede hacer lo que hace.
Les daré otro ejemplo,
el ejemplo es del grupo de infraestructura de Google.
El grupo de infraestructura de Google es el responsable
de mantener el sitio web en funcionamiento 24/7.
Cuando Google estaba por presentar Gmail y YouTube,
ellos sabían que su sistema de almacenamiento de datos no era adecuado.
El jefe del grupo de ingeniería y el grupo de infraestructuras en ese momento
era un hombre llamado Bill Coughran.
Bill y su equipo de liderazgo, al que llama "cerebro de confianza",
tenía que pensar qué hacer con esta situación.
Lo pensaron durante un tiempo.
En vez de crear un grupo para abordar esta tarea,
decidieron permitir que surgieran grupos espontáneamente
con distintas alternativas.
Dos grupos se fundieron.
Uno se conocía como Big Table,
y el otro como Construir Desde Cero.
Big Table propuso construir sobre el sistema actual.
Construir Desde Cero propuso hacer un nuevo sistema.
Por separado, a estos 2 equipos se les permitió trabajar a tiempo completo
en sus enfoques particulares.
En las revisiones de ingeniería, Bill describió su papel como
una "inyección de honestidad en el proceso que propició el debate".
Rápidamente, se animó a los equipos a construir prototipos para
"enfrentar la realidad y probar por sí mismos
las fortalezas y debilidades de sus enfoques particulares".
Cuando Construir Desde Cero compartió su prototipo con el grupo
y las alarmas sonaban a media noche
si algo iba mal en el sitio web,
escucharon en voz alta y clara las limitaciones de su diseño particular.
Conforme la necesidad de una solución se hizo más urgente
y empezaron a entrar los datos, o las pruebas,
se hizo bastante claro que la solución Big Table
era la más adecuada para el momento.
Así que seleccionaron esa.
Pero para asegurarse de no perder el aprendizaje
del equipo Construir Desde Cero,
Bill les pidió a 2 miembros de ese equipo
que se sumaran a un nuevo equipo emergente
para trabajar en el sistema de próxima generación.
Todo este proceso llevó casi 2 años,
pero me dijeron que todos trabajaron a una velocidad vertiginosa.
Ni bien empezaron, uno de los ingenieros le dijo a Bill:
"Estamos todos muy ocupados por culpa de este sistema ineficiente
de ejecutar experimentos en paralelo".
Pero a medida que avanzaba el proyecto, empezó a comprender
la sabiduría de permitir que gente talentosa desplegara sus pasiones.
Admitió: "Si nos hubieras forzado a todos a estar en un equipo,
nos habríamos centrado en probar quién tenía razón, y en ganar,
y no en aprender y descubrir la mejor respuesta para Google".
¿Por qué Pixar y Google pueden innovar una y otra vez?
Porque han dominado las capacidades necesarias para ello.
Saben cómo resolver problemas de manera colaborativa,
saben aprender por descubrimiento,
y saben tomar decisiones integradas.
Algunos de Uds. allí sentados puede que se digan en este momento:
"No sabemos hacer esas cosas en mi organización.
¿Cómo es que lo saben en Pixar
y cómo lo saben en Google?"
Cuando muchas de las personas que trabajaron para Bill nos dijeron
que en su opinión, Bill era uno de los líderes más finos de Silicon Valley,
estuvimos completamente de acuerdo; el hombre es un genio.
El liderazgo es la salsa secreta.
Pero es un tipo distinto de liderazgo,
no del tipo en que pensamos al pensar en gran liderazgo.
Uno de los líderes que conocí desde el principio me dijo:
"Linda, no leo libros sobre liderazgo.
Me hacen sentir mal". (Risas)
"En el primer capítulo dicen que se supone que debo crear una visión.
Pero si trato de hacer algo muy nuevo, no tengo respuestas.
No sé en qué dirección vamos
y ni siquiera sé cómo averiguar cómo llegar allí".
Claro, hay veces en las que el liderazgo visionario
es exactamente lo que se necesita.
Pero si queremos crear organizaciones que puedan innovar una y otra vez,
debemos modificar nuestra comprensión del liderazgo.
Liderar la innovación es crear el espacio
en el que las personas estén dispuestas a trabajar arduamente
en la resolución innovadora de problemas.
En este momento, muchos de Uds. se estarán preguntando:
"¿Cómo es realmente ese liderazgo?"
En Pixar entienden que la innovación no es algo individual.
Los líderes se centran en crear un sentido de comunidad
y en desarrollar esas 3 capacidades.
¿Cómo definen el liderazgo?
Dicen que el liderazgo tiene que ver con crear un mundo
al que la gente quiere pertenecer.
¿A qué clase de mundo quiere la gente pertenecer en Pixar?
Un mundo en el que uno vive en la frontera.
¿En qué centran su tiempo?
No en crear una visión.
En cambio, pasan su tiempo pensando:
"¿Cómo diseñar un estudio con la sensibilidad de una plaza pública
para que las personas interactúen?
Pongamos una política que cualquiera, sin importar su nivel o función,
pueda dejarle notas al director
sobre sus percepciones respecto de una película en particular.
¿Qué podemos hacer para asegurar
que los disruptores, las voces minoritarias de la organización,
hablen claro y sean oídas?
Finalmente, otorguemos crédito de manera muy generosa".
No sé si se han detenido a ver los créditos de una película de Pixar,
pero los bebés nacidos durante una producción se enumeran allí.
(Risas)
¿Cómo pensó Bill su papel?
Bill dijo: "Yo conduzco una organización de voluntarios.
Las personas talentosas no quieren seguirme a cualquier lugar.
Quieren co-crear conmigo el futuro.
Mi tarea es fomentar el modelo abajo-arriba
y que no degenere en caos".
¿Cómo veía él su rol?
"Soy un modelo a seguir, soy un pegamento humano,
soy un conector, un agrupador de puntos de vista.
Nunca soy un dictador de puntos de vista".
¿Consejos sobre cómo ejercita el rol?
Contraten personas que discutan con Uds.
¿Y adivinen qué?
A veces es mejor ser deliberadamente confuso e impreciso.
Algunos de Uds. se preguntarán,
¿en qué están pensando estas personas?
Ellos están pensando:
"Yo no soy el visionario, soy el arquitecto social.
Estoy creando el espacio donde la gente esté dispuesta y pueda
compartir y combinar sus talentos y pasiones".
Si a alguno le preocupa el hecho de no trabajar en Pixar,
o no trabajar en Google,
quiero decirles que aún hay esperanza.
Hemos estudiado muchas organizaciones,
no las organizaciones que uno pensaría
como lugares de innovación.
Estudiamos un consejero general en una empresa farmacéutica
que tenía que pensar cómo unos abogados externos,
19 competidores, colaboraban e innovaban.
Estudiamos al jefe de marketing de una automotriz alemana
donde, fundamentalmente, creían que eran los ingenieros de diseño,
no la gente de marketing, los que podían ser innovadores.
También estudiamos a Vineet Nayar en HCL Technologies,
una empresa de outsourcing de India.
Cuando conocimos a Vineet,
su empresa estaba a punto, en sus palabras, de volverse irrelevante.
Vimos cómo convirtió esa empresa en un dínamo mundial de innovación en TI.
En HCL Technologies, como en muchas empresas,
los líderes habían aprendido a marcar el camino
y a asegurarse de que nadie se desviara de él.
Y él les dijo que era hora
de repensar lo que se suponía que tenían que hacer.
Porque ocurría que todos miraban para arriba
y no se veía esa innovación de abajo arriba
que veíamos en Pixar o en Google.
Empezaron a trabajar en eso.
Dejaron de dar respuestas, dejaron de tratar de dar soluciones.
En cambio, empezaron a ver
a las personas de la base de la pirámide, las chispas jóvenes,
las personas que estaban más cerca de los clientes,
como la fuente de innovación.
Empezaron a transferir el crecimiento de la organización
a ese nivel.
En palabras de Vineet, fue invertir la pirámide
para desatar el poder de los muchos
aflojando el dominio absoluto de los pocos,
y aumentar la calidad y la velocidad de la innovación
que estaba ocurriendo a diario.
Por supuesto, Vineet y los otros líderes que estudiamos,
de hecho, eran visionarios.
Por supuesto, entendieron que ese no era su rol.
Por eso pienso que no es coincidencia que muchos de Uds. no reconocieran a Ed.
Porque Ed, como Vineet, entienden que nuestro rol como líderes
es preparar el escenario, no actuar en él.
Si queremos inventar un mejor futuro,
y sospecho que por eso muchos estamos aquí,
tenemos que reimaginar nuestra tarea.
Nuestra tarea es crear el espacio
donde todas las rebanadas de genio
sean liberadas y aprovechadas,
y traducidas en obras de genio colectivo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)